[Music]
the unfurling of awnings usually marks
the rollout of patio season it's a long
tradition one that actually dates back
centuries early romans were among the
first to seek refuge from the hot sun
under fabric awnings and today design
innovations mean there's always
something new under the sun
with modern mechanisms unfolding and
awning has never been easier
this manual crank system is designed for
a smooth roll out
and for extra convenience there are
motorized awnings operated by remote
control
production begins with the fabric which
comes in a range of weather resistant
synthetics
the seamstress cuts out patterns from
thick acrylic material and sews the
pieces together
here she works on the awning's front
valance a roller keeps the fabric
correctly aligned and stops it from
bunching up as she sews
she stitches a long pocket along the
border
a plastic rod will later be channeled
through it to connect the valance to the
awning framework
[Music]
she traces a scalloped edge onto the
bottom of the valance and then carefully
cuts along the pencil line
with a steady hand she follows the
outline precisely to give the valance
those distinctive curves and notches
workers then position the awning panel
in front of an aluminum tube
they thread the pocketed end of the
awning into a channel in the tube and
then slide a plastic rod into the pocket
this secures the end of the fabric to
the tube it takes two people to avoid
any buckling of the fabric
they insert a plastic cap into one end
of the tube but leave the other end open
for the installation of the motor
they now wind the awning panel around
the tube synchronizing their efforts so
the tension in the roll is equal at both
ends
next rollers carry a squared aluminum
tube to a circular saw
once in position arms descend to steady
the tube and the saw slices it to the
correct length
the cut tube will be the carrier bar an
important part of the awning framework
a worker now builds that framework
starting with the carrier bar
he slides a bracket part way down the
tube and uses it to attach the
retractable arms securing the assembly
with a heavy-duty steel pin
two workers slide connector pieces into
the grooves in the drop bar for the
valance
then they raise the bar and attach the
retractable arms
they install a side bearing in the end
of the connector bar
it's one of two that will support the
awning's main tube
next up is that fabric wrapped tube
they attach it to the framework and tuck
the other end of the awning fabric into
a round slot in the drop bar
they slide another long plastic rod
through a pocket in the fabric to secure
it
they're now ready for the motor it's a
tubular model
he attaches a metal bracket for
assembling the motor to the main
framework
he then equips the tubular motor with
two plastic rings one at each end
powered by the motor these rings will
revolve to open and close the awning
a test confirms that it's fully
operational
he slides the tubular motor into the
open end of the awning tube
he attaches the second side bearing to
the metal bracket
and caps the open end of the drop bar
a few taps with the hammer drives it
down the shaft
he now tests the awning to confirm that
everything unfolds as it should
he tightens some screws and when it's
perfectly operational he'll install the
valance
it takes about an hour to manufacture a
motorized awning
and it should supply about a decade of
shade
[Music]
you